everybody big fails too everybody big
has had more failures and successes I
don't really think about what people
think about me because I feel like if
you try to please everybody you end up
pleasing nobody you have to have an idea
that's innovated you have to be able to
execute and you can't look to the left
of the right to what someone else is
doing to figure out what you're doing
the motivation watch top 10 with believe
nation what suddenly they should 7 I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a woman who went
from having a difficult childhood her
father abandoned the family when she was
four years old having to move away many
times to attend multiple schools to
becoming a best-selling author a star on
the Real Housewives of New York City and
founder of see me girl lifestyle brand
she's Betty Frankel and here's my take
on her top ten rules to success enjoy
also if you want to know what successful
women entrepreneurs like Oprah Winfrey
Mel Robbins Marie Forleo and others have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence to link to join is in
the description below key to success is
what you believe is true for yourself
because being a really really good
listener is one of the most underrated
secrets to success
if you didn't give a [ __ ] what anybody
else thought what's the thing you would
love to be doing with your life
okay let's take it off with rule number
one execute what's the one piece of
advice you would have for another
entrepreneur just starting out it's
about the execution I always bring up
the Winklevoss twins those guys that
said that they created Facebook and the
bottom line is he executed Facebook I
have no idea the answer to that question
he named it he executed it it has
changed the world so it's who executes
10 different people could have the same
idea it's happened
spinning has been around for 25 years
the mash in ice cream the Cold Stone
Creamery did was that Steve's ice cream
in Great Neck 25 years ago it's who's
gonna execute the idea business no
matter what it is it could be tech it
could be food it could be fashion you
have to find your way in people I feel
have great ideas and then how do they
execute the middle and then they keep
hitting roadblocks and how do you get it
done you find your way in you come in at
a different from a different direction
rule number two ignore the opinions of
others I feel that being on television
of being a woman and a strong woman that
I have a responsibility to you know
communicate how I feel and inspire and
be honest and I feel responsibility by
the same token I don't really think
about what people think about me because
I feel like if you try to please
everybody you end up pleasing nobody and
I and I believe that you shouldn't buy
into the love how much people love you
get all jacked up by that or buy into
the hate how much they hate you so I
feel like I'm right down the middle with
that I'm polarizing I know people hate
me people love me and I'm not you know I
don't play favorites if you hate me I
respect it because you know you have an
opinion and you're allowed to and if you
love me you know I love it and it's
great and you're helping pay my you know
mortgage and my kids everything so it is
what it is
rule number three follow your gut the
Real Housewives of any of New York is
our reality show for those of you who
don't know or watch and it was I was at
an event called polo the sport in the
Hamptons which is where like the wealthy
playground in the summer and a girl came
up to me and said we're doing this show
it's called Manhattan moms and they
want ma wealthy moms who are married
with kids to do the show and I said well
I don't even like my boyfriend so I
don't know why you're talking to me
because it was called Manhattan moms at
the time so I talked to the producers
they really liked me because they wanted
me to be there question mark character
sort of the Carrie Bradshaw what am I
gonna happen to me I want to do this
business and and I'm alone and not on a
kid and you know in my 30s and I first
didn't want to do it because I was
scared that I'd already been on a
reality show and I would sort of you
know peg me in that in that hole and a
month later I just kept thinking about
it like that nagging feeling where you
feel like you should be jumping and I
said I feel like I should do this I just
I just have a gut it's not that easy to
get on television and I have a private
eye I'm a natural food chef and so I
decided to do it and it was definitely
the greatest decision I've ever made in
my life business-wise for sure before
hustle when I'm launching a new product
now I have to go back to my original way
of doing it when I didn't have any
marketing dollars any powerful partners
anybody even who knew who I was and what
it really was was blood sweat and tears
it was hustle it was straight hustle and
that's a skill that you kind of always
have to hone in on and have in the early
days I had a small partner who wasn't
willing to spend a head of the brand so
he was willing to kind of spend as
people had ordered but I had I told him
if we build it they will come I'm going
to market this it's going to be on the
show and I told him to shrink-wrap a
vehicle and Skinnygirl I felt it I was
like we're doing this and then people
started flipping out wanting the product
and we couldn't keep up with the supply
and I was ripping my hair out he got so
many gray hairs from from that period
because I would be like get that product
you know we didn't really have money but
I turned that demand into something
positive letting people know letting
people into my struggle I'm sorry we're
trying to keep up with it we'll get it
as fast as we can I couldn't even list
the amount of struggles the number of
struggles and it could so easily have
not happened it happened because I
hustled it didn't happen because it was
a great idea it didn't happen because it
was on television it happened because I
made it happen number five
live your life
while living a great life is uh living
like we live honestly you know I find
that so many people are more worried
about other people thinking they have a
great life than actually having what
they feel is a great life and it's for
me like I really do what I want
I really do exactly what I want in
business in my personal life and it's
been so overused saying I gave zero but
most things I really do give zero it's
about so I only sweat the small stuff so
all the big stuff I'm not really that
worried about rule number six be
invested all seriousness what do you
think the biggest mistake people make
when they're trying to build a brand cuz
you just said you didn't want the brand
to be you and I'm surprised at that I
think that people don't adhere to the
line I think that they there's a
slippery slope and if you have something
successful but you know big shiny
objects come in and people want you to
do different things and happens to me
every day you know this this partner
wants to come in and they want to do
this and I say well wait that's not
really part of the original brand
proposition but well the partner for
example Skinnygirl sparklers which I
love my non-alcoholic beverage I
originally wanted a non sparkling drink
or the natural energy drink that were
coming out with but the partner saw a
space in the sparkling beverage and they
know that's where I won't micromanage
them they know where there was a space
but I said okay but next I want a
natural energy drink so you have to kind
of be able to bob and weave and but if
they had said we want to do a bacon
drink I would say no cuz it has nothing
to do with a better for you brand and I
mean that's a ridiculous example but you
can't just go for the shiny objects and
seriously 99% of celebrities just put
their name on something and they're not
invested and involved rule number seven
study success are there any specific
mentors or or advisers that you would
point out as helping you particularly
what I don't like is that it when I say
that I don't have a mentor it sounds
like I there's no one that I look up to
I look up to so many different business
people but it's more that people that I
read about from afar I look at someone
like Mark Zuckerberg who has changed the
world and is a visionary I look at
someone like Warren Buffett donating
most of his wealth to charity and and
and the way that people's decisions are
made but there's no one person i watch
decisions that Hillary Clinton makes or
/ maid or Trump is making I mean you
kind of garner a lot of different
information from different people I
don't have one person that I go to I
don't actually think that one person
could tell me what I would need to know
every day there'll be a different issue
and I'll think about okay I'm in trouble
in this way from a public relations
perspective so who's the person that I
can think of who's most gone through
that and then tomorrow it's wait now I
need to talk about something in
distribution who do I talk to about that
now I need to talk to somebody who knows
about intellectual property
you don't go to one doctor for every
problem you would have you have an
earache it's not the same doctor if you
wanna get a boob job it's a different
person so I don't think you should rely
on one person again it's exercising the
muscle you can't let the muscle get weak
you have to work out different ways rule
number eight don't fear failure we're
gonna talk about me but it's funny
because that was right when Martha
Stewart got out of jail and she was
going to come on TV and fire Trump and
do her own show and Mark Burnett the
producer said it's gonna be the biggest
show much bigger than Trump show and so
she had a season of a show where she
jumped and it failed I mean even you
know everybody everybody big fails to
everybody big has had more failures and
successes so anyway I came in second on
the Martha Stewart Apprentice and it was
hard cuz you're you know if you're a
perfectionist or you like you know you
want to win and you second isn't winning
but I am a person who's always turned
the negative into a positive
yeah and I I did I used that experience
to get into magazines get on the you
know today's show just little things see
she said something that most people
don't really grasp successful people
have failed far more times than they've
succeeded rule number nine connect with
the audience business is really
difficult and you have to be passionate
and driven and most of them haven't
succeeded because you have to have an
idea that's innovated you have to be
able to execute and you can't look to
the left of the right to what someone
else is doing to figure out what you're
doing I crack the code and did something
that had never been done before in
liquor and it really wasn't because
I had a nice figure and it wasn't
because it was a businesswoman I
connected with the audience my I
connected with the audience as a human
being with my flaws and my life and that
is ultimately why they trusted me to buy
my products it wasn't the other way
around I went on the show to show what I
was doing but that isn't the reason that
I ended up becoming successful and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is solve problems the
CEO and founder of Skinnygirl that's a
heck of a brand it's an amazing brand
it's really exciting that's guys
definitely got like subscribe the room
uh it started out as a low-calorie
margarita I was the first person to ever
create a low-calorie cocktail marketed
to women in in a world that is run by
men and marketed to men and it was
pretty destructive and it was definitely
a game changer and there was a time when
it was the fastest-growing cocktail in
history and so it's been amazing but
I've turned it into not only the
margarita it's turned into everything in
practical solutions for women from wines
vodkas nutritional bars proteins that's
like what don't you have microwave
popcorn I mean microwave popcorn
non-alcoholic beverages sweeteners salad
dressings candy coming coffee coming but
it's a it's spaces that I see the holes
where there's a something to solve now
that a special bonus gift from Bethany
on how to go for it that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point lighting questions
time to move from just watching another
video to taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
we'll leave your answers in the comments
below here we go question number one
what problem are you in the business of
solving number two what failure are you
fearing that you need to let go of and
number three how can you live your life
more honestly
yes tell us a little bit about what that
that phrase means you know it's not it's
not about always being in a good mood
because we could all tell by tonight's
show that I'm not always that it's about
the fact that you go for what you want
to get and and there's no such thing as
no and you get derailed and sometimes
you don't know you know where you are
and you can't see the forest from the
trees I've had tons of jobs and tons of
failures everybody always been on the
road I've always been moving forward and
I've always known I'm gonna get it I'm
gonna be something I'm gonna help people
I have something and you know everyone's
told me no along the way and you have to
go in your own go for your own good and
grab your balls and go for it
if you like this video check out the top
10 I need on justice out but the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I spent a lot of time in my head
fantasizing about being a superhero and
about being somebody else then what what
would it be like to live